previously on numberphile James grime
made a video about stacking cannonballs
I'm a big fan he told the brilliant
story Rayleigh asking Harriette to work
out how many cannonballs he had in a
pile but he did not mention the number
4900 which has at one point in my
favorite number this is the elite club
of numbers which have been my favorite
number at some point in time not a small
club it is still exclusive it's finite
exactly which is tiny in the biggest
compared to all and roughly zero percent
of numbers are in that Club it's a lot
numbers for a while my favorite number
was 3000 at the moment which is the
number 2025 one of my favorite numbers
is 16 when how it sat down and did the
working up for the cannonballs who came
up with the great equation that you end
up with and outside of n plus 1 ounce 2n
plus 1 divide that by 6 so for a stack
of cannonballs in high that's how many
cannonballs you've got in there and
people look to that for a while went
okay that's kind of fun after Rayleigh
had done his work people were like well
that's a square base pyramid what if
they were just in a square I said like a
cube just like a big old flat square on
the ground and so people said the one
that were hang on hang on can you find
some other number squared which gives
you a square base pyramid this is it
4900 so this was in 1875 Lucas of Lucas
number Fame what a guy
best numbers and that's why I think the
Lucas numbers are vastly superior
Fibonacci did nothing on this right
Lucas found 4900 which can be a
cannonball stack so like James showed
you could take these and put them in a
square based pyramid 24 layers high
perfect square based pyramid or you
could arrange them into a giant square
70 by 70 flat and it turns out it's the
only number that can do that how
exciting is that
right so and it wasn't proved until
nineteen
18 someone managed to prove 4900 is the
only number which can be both a square
and a square based pyramid which is why
it's called the cannonball number cool
the next question should be are there
any others right because I've just said
it's the only square and square based
pyramid well then why would there be a
question of are there any others you've
told me there's no other showed us there
are other ways to stack things you can
have different based pyramids when I
first saw this big final Lukas I was
like oh that's great
really cool can you favorite number for
a while and I was like wow what about
other based pyramids so I wrote a little
computer program because I mean this one
is easy enough there's your formula
which will give you number of
cannonballs and a stack of a certain
height that's the formula for the area
of a square very straightforward there
are more complicated formulas for the
area of a pentagon or a hexagon or an
octagon of cannonballs the pyramid is
just sequential adding up all of those
numbers in a row so what this number
actually is it's the only square number
which is also the sum of the sequence of
square numbers starting at 1 so I was
looking for other shape numbers whatever
argon numbers which are also the some of
those same argon numbers starting from
one same shape all the way my hope is
that for each shape and its accompanying
pyramid there's a one number for each
wouldn't it be great ok Pentagon's
none well I can't prove there a number I
couldn't find any I gave it a go
couldn't find fend against found a
hexagon 946 you could take those
cannonballs and put them into one giant
hexagon with sides of twenty-two
cannonballs down every single side or
you could rearrange them into a
hexagonal based pyramid 11 hi there's
only one so there you are but there
could be another one floating out how
did you go not that high I can't
remember exactly I got bored and I wrote
another bit of code so I only found one
although I got some bad news about
octagons there too okay I got 1,000
and 45 and I've got 5985 they both can
form an octagon and they both can form
an octagon based pyramid so sadly there
was more than one does that make you sad
or happy that's that discovery I was
kind of happy because it was not what I
expected right I said it going and then
it's pan out and you want the hex again
I'm for a heptagon and then BOOM
- for octagon and then I was like well
how far can we go that's just pathetic
going so I coded it up I hit go and I
went to bed and then I woke up the next
morning and staring me in the face was
ninety billion five hundred and twenty
five million eight hundred and one
thousand seven hundred and thirty which
is a thirty one thousand two hundred and
sixty five gone number it can either be
arranged as one giant thirty one
thousand two hundred and sixty five are
gone and each site would have two
thousand four hundred and seven cannon
balls each for each of the thirty 1265
sides or you can make a thirty one
thousand two hundred sixty five argon
pyramid which is two hundred and fifty
nine levels high so this number works
for both the shape and the pyramid for
this ridiculous sized shape and I found
it first
right so I that number I don't think
anyone else did ever bothered doing this
right so this number has existed since
the beginning of time as all numbers
have and it just sat there waiting for
one day someone with enough spare time
and a laptop to discover it and so I
walked out in the morning I looked on my
laptop and this number was smiling back
at me and I was like you've been waiting
a long time number that someone finally
came for you
someone finally came for the thirty one
thousand two hundred and sixty-five
agonal number which is also a thirty one
thousand two hundred sixty five ago
based Herman ma yeah seriously
I'm proud of you really it is what it
took I bet I was so pleased when I was
like that's mine I found that and it's
cool it's not useful well I love it
and so that's when 4,900 stopped being
my favorite number and I upgraded to
just over 90 billion so the people whose
names you're seeing on screen at the
moment these are supporters they help us
make better videos make more videos put
music in them pay for animation if you'd
like to join them there are links on the
screen and down in the video description
and if you want to show Matt Parker some
extra love why don't you consider his
book humble pie this is what it looks
like it's all about mathematical
mistakes it's a great read it's becoming
a best-seller which is unusual for a
mathematical book use the link down in
the video description if you want to get
a signed copy from Matt at the time of
recording the book hasn't yet been
released in the United States but and
this is just between us you can get it
using that link